just look at this
there's something truly magical about
the images of award-winning photographer
frank
relley through his lens trees houses and
other common objects
are transformed into vivid even haunting
scenes
works that now have a place in both
private collections and prestigious
museums
including the smithsonian our jamie wax
joined the new orleans native at his
gallery
and out on the water to observe the
painstaking process of capturing these
stunning portraits
of the world around us photographs
are a powerful way of of communicating
for people
and have been and i think they will
continue to be for a long time
there are many photographers who focus
on human subjects to express
themes such as connection loneliness
aging and loss frank really manages to
express
all those human themes and more in his
photographs
without ever actually featuring a single
human
moments like today you know when we you
know i have a chance to zoom out and
reflect and i'm not in the midst of it
all
i realize it's like oh wow this all
these
pieces of my life have come together and
it feels amazing
the louisiana native has been
photographing landscapes
natural and man-made for 17 years
when one of his photographs was featured
as the cover image of dan baum's 2009
best-selling book about hurricane
katrina
nine lives more people began to take
interest in relly's work
what impact did that have on
your art and your ability to connect
with a wider audience
for me it was very powerful to have the
image on the outside of that book
uh speak to the lives that were on the
inside of it it's super special because
ultimately i'm trying to get people's
attention
through the images and so when it goes
out as broadly as that then it's super
powerful
reli's artistic focus now is mainly on
louisiana's bayous and swamps
utilizing evocative lighting and long
exposure times
he creates stunning and emotional images
your work evolved from these dramatic
photographs
of architectural structures in louisiana
to nature scenes swamp scenes isolated
trees
that evolution happened in multiple
different ways after i've been
photographing the architecture in new
orleans for a while
i wanted to get back to my love of the
natural world but i didn't know the path
to it
hurricane katrina of course happened and
that was a huge water story how water
came into the city of new orleans
and then the disaster with the oil spill
in the gulf of mexico
that was another story that was
connected to the water both of these
were
dramatic photographic events that
captured all of our attention
and i i just realized that in louisiana
all of the stories
come from the water the photographs are
made of
you know natural subjects they're made
of trees and they're made of water and
they're made of skies and stars but
they're made for people
and the most profound way that we
connect with
people is through relationships and
something we can all understand and we
all
understand the shape of an embrace
they become something that has a human
connection in it
relly's former studio director shimsi
frazelle
believes that human connection has the
power to reflect both our pessimism
and our optimism sometimes together
i think that frank through his work has
never
really shied away from the potential for
tragedy and what that can do to
an environment what that can do to
someone's spirit but i think through his
technique
as a photographer what his work has
always done for me
is sort of blended the reality
of potential tragedy with hope
a lot of his photographs are shot in
remote areas
at night a place he says fear and
possibility
coexist the process is intense
at times with rallying up to 25 feet of
water for
hours at a time and he's not usually
alone you have been in situations where
15 to
20 alligators are surrounding you in
maybe 16 feet of water
and you're right there yes and you say
you're not afraid of that situation
no i know that people in those
situations
you know i know that people are afraid
but i typically feel very calm in the
natural world and that calm
you know being down in the water despite
the fact that there are alligators in
the water
is a calming experience for me i am
stuck in swamp mud
i have no idea how you do this it was
something i just
had to experience firsthand are you
looking for humanity
in these things that you shoot sometimes
it's a feeling that you get from the
tree in the middle of the night
the only souls for miles deep
in moropa swamp in freezing water
sinking in quicksand mud filled with
alligators in a hibernation-like state
it was frank relley's happy place
how's that feel that feels great you
have a method of
treading water and floating so that you
don't disturb that
that long exposure how important is
lighting
in the emotional content that you
capture lighting is everything
i mean lighting is the language it's the
music
of of photography you know there's the
what you're photographing there's the
subject
and the light is the feel you know being
able to to work at night and
you know in shape light to create that
feeling it's it's the key
and to know frank relly and his work
is to know that the light doesn't just
come from without
but also within i look at your smile
right now i mean you are really living
your boyhood dream in a lot of ways i
completely am
and i'm i i feel so lucky for that it's
amazing
finding that path has been you know full
of challenges and hurdles and right now
in this moment i feel
really grateful for you know being able
to make my way there
and excited about what comes next for
cbs this morning saturday
jamie wax new orleans he seems so
delightful and i tell you he's bringing
to light
the conditions of the cypress swamp so
many cypress trees
are endangered now so i know that those
pictures
people are going to buy them and perhaps
they'll tell a story
they're beautiful yeah i mean they're
just stunning images
really and we all know lighting good
lighting he's right odds are all about
that lighting yeah